-Performing "Walkin"
from his album
"Melt My Eyez See Your Future,"
give it up for Denzel Curry.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Ladies and gentlemen,
I'd like to introduce
The Cold-Blooded Soul Band.
And I go by the name
of Denzel Curry.
And I know sometimes
that life gets hard sometimes.
But I want to tell everybody
in this crowd right now
and everybody that's watching
at home,
I just need y'all to listen
to me and know...
♪ Clear a path
as I keep on walkin' ♪
♪ Ain't no stoppin' in
this dirty, filthy, rotten ♪
♪ Nasty, little world
we call our home ♪
♪ They get blickies poppin' ♪
♪ Ain't no option
for my partners ♪
♪ So they resort
to scams and robbin' ♪
♪ Take away stress,
we ganja-coppin' ♪
♪ Blow it all out,
it's all forgotten ♪
♪ Keep on walkin' ♪
♪ Ain't no stoppin'
in this dirty, filthy, rotten ♪
♪ Nasty little world
we call our home ♪
♪ They get blickies poppin' ♪
♪ Ain't no option
for my partners ♪
♪ So they resort
to scams and robbin' ♪
♪ Take away stress,
we ganja-coppin' ♪
♪ Blow it all out,
it's all forgotten ♪
♪ Walkin' with my back
against the sun ♪
♪ I've been runnin'
all my life ♪
♪ That's way before
my life begun ♪
♪ Since my birth
and seconds on Earth ♪
♪ I been the first one
to confront ♪
♪ All of these cycles
that get recycled ♪
♪ Makin' it stifle
while I stunt ♪
♪ Roll me a blunt
so I forget it ♪
♪ But it make the details
look so vivid ♪
♪ Went through a lot of things
in the last year ♪
♪ Then I said,
"I'ma handle my business" ♪
♪ I been 180 to talk
to one lady ♪
♪ She been regulatin'
on how I feel ♪
♪ Describe it as raw and real ♪
♪ I'm dealin'
with all the ills ♪
♪ I'm tearin' up
like I'm on Dr. Phil ♪
♪ Ain't no use, you gotta walk ♪
♪ Who the hell said,
"Stop the track," Bruh? ♪
♪ Let a real brother talk ♪
-♪ yeah ♪
-♪ I walk from the women,
I walk from the friendship ♪
♪ I walk from some digits
and lately, my brother ♪
♪ I'm feelin' indifferent ♪
♪ I wish all the best,
and believe that, I meant it ♪
♪ Sentence, run-on sentence ♪
♪ Pray to God for repentance ♪
♪ Beat the odds at all costs, I
wan' share it with my infants ♪
♪ Way before he start crawlin' ♪
♪ Wash my sins, keep ballin' ♪
♪ I just gotta stay focused ♪
♪ I just gotta keep walkin' ♪
♪ Keep on walkin',
ain't no stoppin' ♪
♪ In this dirty, filthy,
rotten ♪
♪ Nasty, little world
we call our home ♪
♪ They get blickies poppin' ♪
♪ Ain't no option
for my partners ♪
♪ So they resort
to scams and robbin' ♪
♪ Take away stress,
we ganja-coppin' ♪
♪ Blow it all out,
it's all forgotten ♪
♪ Keep on walkin',
ain't no stoppin' ♪
♪ In this dirty,
filthy, rotten ♪
♪ Nasty, little world
we call our home ♪
♪ They get blickies poppin' ♪
♪ Ain't no option
for my partners ♪
♪ So they resort
to scams and robbin' ♪
♪ Take away stress,
we ganja-coppin' ♪
♪ Blow it all out,
it's all forgotten ♪
♪ Walk, walk, walk, walk, walk,
walk, walk, walk, walk, walk ♪
walk, walk, walk ♪
Turn me up! Go!
♪ Walk, walk, walk, walk, walk,
walk, walk, walk, walk, walk ♪
♪ Walk, walk, walk, walk, walk ♪
♪♪
-That's how you do it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is how you do it!